this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
first thank you all for coming it's
really nice to see such a such a big
group here so I'm really excited to
share some work that I started last year
this is all very new and this is these
are really the initial results there
haven't been that many studies done
really at all on on the robot a lot of
home testing but nothing in a larger
replicated experiment so today we'll
talk a lot about turtle but first I
wonder how many of you have robots raise
your hand and keep your hand raised
does anybody have a weeding robot okay I
have four I have four over here I just
adopted last year okay keep your hands
raised does anybody have a drone okay
and if Jen Thomas Murphy was here she
she has one she recorded some of the
footage all right what about a
dishwasher okay it's not mobile but a
lot of us have dishwashers and laundry
are in washing machines so there you go
everybody has a robot in some sort of
fashion and that's that's the trend
increasing dependence on automation so
first I want to start with why go away
from what's already been really useful
herbicides have been relied on for
decades now they're cheap and they're
still the go-to option for for many
growers especially at large scales but
there are problems with herbicides you
see a figure here of the number of cases
of herbicide resistance on the rise
increasing these are unique cases of
herbicide resistance but there are other
issues with herbicides to off off target
impacts so you have health and
environmental concerns and there are no
new herbicide technologies coming out
there hasn't been a new mode of action
since the 1980s so we're kind of coming
to the end of this this huge resource
that is herbicides so we really need to
be thinking about what's next what's the
next step
and it's not necessarily organic AG so
you might think okay well if we rip up
the soil that's a good way to kill weeds
and not use herbicides but there are
many problems with disturbing the soil
in this way and big bigger and bigger
tractors have been the trends and the
the consequences here are soil loss and
soil degradation so organics not
necessarily the way to go
herbicides aren't really the way to go
what what are the options are there any
other tools that can be sustainable so
bigger and bigger tractors have have
been the trend and yet there there are
issues in this in this trajectory one
example is the impact on soil compaction
so just show a little bit of
introductory data here the number of
passes increases here as does cone index
or soil compaction and there's a big
difference here too with conventional
tillage versus direct seeding or no-till
so with conventional tillage there's
just increasing capacity for the soil to
be compacted so I strongly believe we're
at the precipice of a big paradigm shift
in agriculture as a whole giving digital
technologies and specifically in weed
control because of issues with
herbicides and organic or a lot of the
reliance in organic on disturbing the
soil that's not to say that all organic
practices require that there are many
cultural practices that are also trying
to get away from the repeated
disturbance of the soil so we could go
backwards we could go back to hand
weeding and in some cases I think that
is going to be necessary he escapes weed
escapes after an herbicide application
might need to be controlled by hand
weeding if you let one Palmer amaranth
plant for example go to seed that has
you know escaped an herbicide
application that's basically setting the
stage for many many years of Palmer
amaranth seeds in the soil so
one plant going to see it can cause many
issues down the line so hand waiting in
that case might really be a good a good
good path however I don't think we
should fully go back there are some new
technologies and I put mowing up here
not because it's a new technology but
maybe we can use it as a cultural
practice why not mow in between our
annual crops annual crops what if we
leave a small living layer of grasses in
between our annual crops maybe that
could be possible with technologies such
as robots foaming has anybody heard of
this this maybe isn't super new either
but foaming uses the heat and the
insulative power of the bubbles and the
foam to kill weeds so foaming might
actually be something that's increasing
in in use in for weed control
electrocution you know you could vac the
weeds there's a lot of research right
now and farmers are actually using this
there's one at least in New York State a
grower that's using electrocution to
kill weeds on his farm and microwaving
this is something I really know very
little about but there are other
technologies out there that are probably
going to be elevated as a result of
decreasing effectiveness of herbicides
as a main option some of these still
require large tractors and energy a lot
of energy needs to go into using any
form of tractor that I that I know of I
don't think there are solar powered
tractors out there yet but we'll get to
the solar powered aspect of the the
turtle in just a minute
drones drones for spraying micro doses
of herbicides that can really cut down
on the volume of herbicides applied but
carrying enough herbicide to apply to a
whole field that there are downsides
there too in terms of energy and
scouting I think drones could be a
really good tool for scouting where are
the weeds in the field if weeds aren't
distributed evenly across the field
they're often very patchy and sometimes
you're looking for maybe just that one
escape so I think drones could be a
really important tool here but then we
get to robots okay here's one example of
a robotic leader it's pretty big it's
still on that that trend of bigger is
better maybe but it has very big solar
panels this is a solar-powered robotic
leader it applies micro doses of an
herbicide made by eco robotics company
and this is a little bit old but I think
this industry is likely to be worth even
more than 400 million I think this is
really on the uptick as far as
technologies that are being welcomed in
large-scale agriculture all right so
that's just a little bit about how the
Eco robotics one works but along with
the change in the and the welcoming of
tiny houses it's not just in the tiny
house movement it's also in Ag and one
example is a small robot company out of
the UK they have a few different robots
that are small and they're supposed to
be small not to use just one in a field
but they're scalable how big is your
field you can basically use as many
robots as as necessary and a couple
other examples from nioh a french
company they have three different robots
right now one for different vegetable
scenario and then larger scale models
for for other industries just quickly
showing some examples here and also farm
wise a SAN francisco-based company
that's using the imagery imaging
technology to know exactly where your
crop plant is is located and to track
that batch crop plant through the
growing season to be able to kill all of
the other plants that are not designated
as the desirable plan
okay so maybe bigger isn't better
necessarily maybe we just need more
smaller units not necessarily turtle but
I'm going to show you some data that I
think will support the idea that maybe a
small robot is the way to go and we
don't necessarily need to go bigger
bigger bigger and what I think Jo will
mention too that this is solar-powered
it's just a really neat way I think to
capture the sun's energy to weed our
Gardens and that's where I will hand it
off to Joe he's going to talk a little
bit about the genesis of turtle so
hopefully you wonder where where where
turtle came from it it really had a
divine origin I can tell you that no
actually it came from a it's sort of
after a company that I had founded
before I used to work at this company
called harvest automation and what
harvest automation robots do is they
they solve the spacing problem on
nursery and greenhouse farms so you
bring the the pots with the plants in
them to the field you set them down and
then rather than have an army of workers
like if you notice the guy in the
background he's doing the spacing the
old-fashioned way he's walking back and
forth instead you have robots to do this
so as a result of working at harsh
automation I got interested once again
in agriculture and I was looking and and
the reason that I was interested in
agriculture because it seems like
there's so many opportunities for robots
in agriculture and I'm always looking
for ways to to bring more robots into
the world and while I was was thinking
about this I was trying to figure out
you know what what would how would
robots benefit and a way that a lot of
people have thought of is you have
robots that go out and weed farm fields
so I thought about doing this well I was
at harvest I thought about trying to
make another way another robot that
would would I thought of some way
robots could be effective at this cost
effective and I couldn't come up with
any ideas that were better than what I
saw lots of other people already doing
so I kind of put that aside for a while
until I went to this conference in in
Boston called Robo madness
and it's one of my favorite conferences
and there I encountered a an
acquaintance of mine who suggested the
idea of how about robots that we home
gardens and that actually changes the
problem just enough that whereas I
couldn't figure out a cost-effective way
to make a robot that we'd a farm field I
could come up with a way a
cost-effective way of making a robot
that weeds a home garden so I left
harvest automation in June of 2015 and
started and sucked in some other folks
to work on this with me and we started
building iterations of little robots
that would weed a home garden and we
started with with Lego which is where
lots of robots start and it went through
a bunch of iterations actually we spent
about a year about a year doing this and
we finally got to a form that we thought
this will actually work we can be
cost-effective it'll it'll do the thing
that it's supposed to do so it's time to
take the next step and the next step was
to do a Kickstarter campaign so the
Kickstarter campaign was but it was
really surprisingly effective we we
ended up being in the in in terms of
money collected for a project we ended
up being then top 1/3 of 1% while
Kickstarter projects so we got a whole
bunch of folks who signed up on
Kickstarter and we kept doing some
pre-sales after the Kickstarter and we
got to about half a million dollars in
in pledges from that and then we had to
ship the robots so I want you to note I
go from here we are this great promise
and then we have to ship the robots too
and then we ship the robots it takes
like a second for me to get from one
slide to the next
took over a year to get from the
previous slide to this slide so get into
the place where you can actually build
these things put them in a box and give
them to somebody who wants to do buy one
is it's it's not not trivial or quick
but anyway this it shows how the robot
actually works it's supposed to speak oh
well if it was speaking what it would
tell you that the robot runs around it
finds and it shows you even better here
or what runs around it finds if it
notices a weed it senses the weed and a
robot
it senses the weed with the weed sensor
on the bottom there's a little weed
whacker behind that the the weed whacker
turns on and chops the weed down when it
gets to a plant that you want it detects
the plant with a sensor on the front and
it turns away from and that basically
goes all that you need to do to to build
a robot that they'll weed your garden
plus make it waterproof and not get
stuck in and all of the other things so
it doesn't work absolutely everywhere
the the picture on the left is actually
from one of our turtle customers who
sent this telling us that this is the
first time in in 30 years that he had
come back from a vacation and found that
his garden was not actually choked with
weeds as the turtle kept working while
while he was off having fun but there's
the places where it would have some
trouble is if you just finished
rototilling your garden and it looks
like this turtle won't work in this
garden until you have you've raked away
the the ruts and the ridges and then
it'll work fine but there are some
places where really doesn't work at all
and that is places where the the slopes
are really steep or the the plants are
our planets or Vince Lee that turtle
can't go in between them so something
that we expect
that the robot again there's a
weedwacker on the bottom of the robot
and when we were designing the we were
designing the robot what we thought was
okay
the weed whacker is gonna do all the
work it'll cruise along the weeds have
to grow up to a certain height before
they can be detected by the weed sensor
but when that happens that'll turn on
the whacker and it'll cut the weed
so what we expected to see in our
company garden was we expected to see a
lot of little green stumps where the
robot had cut the weeds down but instead
what we saw was we just didn't come up
and our hypothesis was that and still is
that basically what's happening in the
fact that the wheels and perhaps with
some help from the whacker are churning
just the surface of the soil a little
bit as soon as the weed germinates it
gets it gets brushed in such a way that
it tends to kill the the sprouting part
and that that that it may be that much
or most of the the weed killing action
is because of the wheels rather than
than the whacker so the way that the
Cornell connection happened at least
from my point of view is out of the blue
I got this email from Christine or she
said give me a robot and and the later
she said no give me four robots but it
turned out it was it was it was a good
idea it worked out really well
and I was like I came down earlier I'm
back in last summer and and and the
rigor with which she conducted these
these experiments and how well the robot
worked is just any way beyond anything
that I could ever have done so it's it's
worked out really well and it's gotten
some good results that she'll uh she'll
tell you about so just to go on a little
bit about the potential for this kind of
technology we have a lot of plans for
the robots that we will build next and
since we discovered that we don't
necessarily need the weed whacker it's
actually possible to build an even
smaller robot that will work in more
densely packed Gardens
that just uses the wheels alone to kill
the robots in this robot we actually
attached little exacto blades to where
the Walker goes don't try this at home
but it actually does work you can make a
tiny little lawnmower from the robot by
doing something like this we actually
have ideas about how to make totally
finger-safe lawn mowing attachment but
we haven't haven't done that quite yet
so so there's also a possibility instead
of just bouncing around which is what
turtle does now if instead you followed
the rows you could basically get a lot
more area one turtle would be able to
cover a lot more area than the current
one does it's just that you would have
to plant your garden in rows rather than
just sort of individual plants we've
also had ideas about building a robot
that just sweeps all the debris off your
deck and keeps it always clean and we've
had an idea about how to build a robot
that eliminates the weeds that grow up
in your patio between the pavers what we
would like to get to at some point is so
at first I didn't know how to build a
robot for farm fields but as a result of
working on turtle I think I do now and
so this is a one product that we would
like to get to to someday this this is
Photoshop we don't actually have this
product yet but that's what we want to
get to we want to get to a robot that
can compete with herbicides on a cost
basis so we have a what I think is
really cool consumer product here but
don't think that there is some
deep-pocketed giant corporation behind
it
the folks who who made this robot and
took it all the way through the
Kickstarter and through the first
shipment so this is all of us this is
the entire company right here so what we
are doing now is we're riding the tiger
so our company is a start-up and what we
have we think is a is a really
innovative product we have a great team
and we've got a really promising start
and to fulfill that that promise what we
are doing now is we are raising funds
and we're talking to VCS and suchlike
and we think that the product that we
have here is comparable to to rumba we
think that the market is about the same
size or maybe bigger even then rumbas
market and currently I robot as a 1.5
billion dollar company so that's where
we're aiming for
but it is a start-up and if investors
don't invest or if gardeners don't buy
robots then the tiger is going to get a
hearty meal that's my part out of the
blue this was really because I was
interested in incorporating more digital
AG into the weeds course that I've been
teaching and so I was doing some
research and and it came up pretty
quickly the the weeding robot and I
could imagine using this in my own
garden I have two rumbas actually one
upstairs one downstairs and so I have
had an interest in in robots for some
time myself and so the first robot I got
was just one I only got one the first
time and I did a really small trial up
at Caldwell field just to see would this
work on you know a typical soil that we
have on campus and I set up the
experiment just with the little guards
that come included with with the product
and I was really impressed this is what
we had what we saw after just a few
weeks early in the season last last
spring so I asked Joe if he would send
me three more and and he did and I
thought that was kind of the minimum
that we would need for to run an
experiment so with a lot of help from
farm services and Matt Ryan and I'll
list everybody who helped we came up
with this in this experiment and not
just a small little one plot
but we use area in the crop garden and
in field L up at all dwell field also
and to begin in this one field we were
going from sod or an old hay field
pretty much so this is an established
community and so we expected a lot of
weed pressure we expected a lot in the
seed bank but we also wanted to over
seed just to make sure there there were
going to be enough seeds to really
evaluate the effectiveness so this is
our intern last summer from Columbia
Maria Paula is over seeding with an
earth way cedar for different species
we're using cover crop species but we're
kind of expecting them to act like our
weeds these are our mimic mimicked weeds
and the next thing we needed was a set
of barriers so you could see some of
them scattered on the left here and this
came from a pile that I found up at
Caldwell field and the the true use of
these are vertical supports for pallet
shelving so just a pile that wasn't
being used unfortunately they're very
heavy so that was the biggest downside
we ended up using two by fours later on
which is what I would recommend if this
were to be redone Scott and our interns
really had to use some some muscles to
move these around but we set up two
different locations one on the Left ears
in the crop garden and the other in
field L at Caldwell field so this is our
new field if you will and this is our
old field and we want to say so the
plots were 6 by 8 feet or 1.8 by 2.4
meters big and let's see this is after
setting it up it was a hard day so this
is Julie just saying oh I'm so glad this
is over with but we set up a randomized
complete block design and let's see in
each of the fields so these are our four
treatments turtle with the trimmer'
turtle without the trimmer and then two
controls a weedy control and then hand
weeded control and we did by me and I
did record that but I won't show you
that
so in three consecutive weeks we
evaluated how well turtle works so this
was at the end of July through three
weeks and in August last summer and
there it is so we alternated the robots
from blocks one and three in mornings
and blocks two and four in the afternoon
so those were set and we used the
charging capacity so that we had enough
energy to get through the whole hour we
also had to have software adjustments
made on the production software just so
that it would run for that long it's set
to turn off at 70% charge
we had it altered so that it would make
it through 50% charge and we randomized
the turtle units across the trimmer and
no trimmer treatment so I was just
switching the trimmer between robots and
I had to replace the trimmers as well
partway through if you want you could
come look at them afterwards they just
get worn down a little bit so that's one
thing that will need to be replaced I
have my kids out there helping a little
bit they really like the robots a lot
but they also like hoeing so they do
they do some of both all right so the
hand weeding for for me it took three to
five minutes or so per to a hand weed
per plot and I thought that was kind of
interesting data to collect and you we
could go you know a little bit more in
the calculations back-of-the-envelope
calculations how much weeding effort
would it take for you know a human to
hand weed versus the robot and so it was
pretty different the robots spending two
hours per week in these plots which is
which is quite a bit this is only 48
square feet and yet Joe is just telling
me that now one robot can actually hover
and maintain 200 square feet of garden
space so this is kind of a lot of
robotic weeding effort in these small
plots but we kind of wanted to see what
what it could do at its best
alright so this is some drone footage
that Jen Thomas Murphy collected in the
center here this is actually the weedy
control
this is in the middle of the experiment
and actually maybe more towards the
beginning of the experiment there aren't
that many weeds in this particular field
it's a it's a pretty hard soil so it's
difficult or small seeded weeds to
emerge and here this is a trimmer
treatment and the other one that you saw
on the right was the no trimmer
treatment so this is just a little bit
of footage to to whet your appetite for
the results and this also shows you how
well the area is covered so we noticed
that there's a little bit of an edge
affect the robot seems to spend more
time around the edge so when we
collected data we only collected the
data from the center of these plots and
Joe mentioned that's something that can
be changed as far as the software you
could change how the robot moves and if
it senses a barrier you know maybe you
can spend more time away from that
barrier anyways there's pretty good
coverage throughout the plot and again
we had it set to run for a whole hour so
there's one hour weeding session alright
so just one another example at the edge
or barrier effect sometimes it would get
stuck and you could see it just spinning
its wheels sometimes if it went for more
than a few seconds I would move it and I
also have the the record of how long it
spent spinning just because I downloaded
the log files afterwards
so that's a whole nother data set that I
haven't really explored too much but if
I notice it didn't have the full hour
run time I would put it back in four to
make sure it had a full hour of run time
this is towards the end of the
experiment you could see the we D
control here in the bottom left and this
is really close to the end of the
experiment I'm going a little bit
quickly so that we have time for some
questions but on the left this is the
with a we D control looked like three
weeks after we started so this is
basically three weeks in one day after
the rototilling and there was also
rolling so I didn't mention that
rototilling and rolling were part of the
seedbed preparation and on the right
this is the hand weeded control so these
are the two
extremes what happens if we don't do any
weeding and what happens if we do pretty
intensive right I thought sweat inducing
flavor all right so then what are the
turtle treatments look like drum roll
please this is the turtle with trimmer
on the Left looks almost as good maybe
better even than the hen we did control
in some pots and without the trimmer
there's still some plants there and
you'll see in the and the other results
to the turtle without the trimmer did
not perform as well as that with the
trimmer considering the production
wheels these are not the production
wheels I'll get to that in a minute
alright so the turtle effect on weed
covers is just total weed cover or plant
abundance and will focus on the blue
bars first so the higher the percentage
cover the the worse the weeding effort
really was so you'd have more of a yield
loss the bigger the bar is so with the
weedy control you know you're gonna have
a lot of weed competition with your
crops and yet if you compare it to the
turtle in this case in this field with
their blue bars they're still in effect
even without the trimmer you're seeing a
reduction from about 50% weed covered
down to 30% we cover so in this
particular location in the crop garden
there was a big effect even with just
the turtle without the trimmer but if
you look at the hand weed control versus
turtle with the trimmer this is really
an astounding result you're getting as
good weed control with the with the
robot including the trimmer as you as my
hand weeding effort so those are not
statistically different which really is
a pretty good result for the turtle and
I showed just a little I'm showing just
a little bit of statistics if you're
interested in the stats I have all of
the code I'm willing to share I did my
stats in are I used Elmer model I did
use a square root transformation for
this data and he means for post-hoc
means comparison
all right so now I have letters up here
for the other field as well no
difference in this second field field l
between the we D control and the T - but
there's definitely improve and
improvement in weeding capacity with the
width trimmer okay forty-seven species
were recorded I won't go into much more
of the actual species than this for the
species were the ones that we had over
seated but 43 were present in the seed
bank or in the propagule Bank many
rhizomes I think we're emerging in in
our crop garden location all right so I
won't spend too much time on this I did
find an effects of the treatment on weed
diversity though I didn't see a
difference when the post hoc means
analysis it does look like diversity
measured by the Shannon diversity index
based on the cover data is reduced in in
the turtle plus the trimmer treatment
all right and what if we look at the
monocots versus dicots I would expect a
difference considering the trimmer only
works up to one inch so it's not
trimming much below that one inch add a
little bit of an angle but we would
expect plants that have a growing point
below that I eat grasses that have a
growing point below the soil surface or
monocots or sedges included here to are
going to be selected for based on this
this robot as well as any dicots or
broadleaf plants that have really low
growing habits such as this purse laying
common purslane maybe you could escape
or be selected for based on this this
weeding approach so just to compare
effective dicots versus monocots and
you'll see here first if you're just
looking at dicots you're getting an
effect just with the wheels the wheels
are doing a fairly good job at reducing
the abundance of your broadleaf weed
species and the same is not necessarily
true for the monocots so basically the
inclusion here briefly is that turtle is
more effective on broadleaf weeds than
on grasses which we we kind of expected
and maybe it's not surprising either
that most of the herbicide resistant
weeds are grasses so this I think is a
really good time to start thinking about
which weeds will be selected for and
really anticipate which weeds could be
resistant to this kind of machine and to
try to be thinking ahead and not run
into the same issue that we've run into
with herbicides just a couple of the
observations we found that if even a
little bit of moisture was there on the
soil surface this is after do it was a
completely dry clear day but there was
due on the soil surface and it really
attaches to the wheels and gets stuck on
Joe has observed that this will fall off
as the soil dries out in the morning
hours but we would run our trials at
9:00 in the morning so it wasn't that
early in the morning and also some of
them would develop this cone shape and I
have an example of what a cone-shaped
wheel might look like and so it's
interesting that that's the shape the
soil would take on as it builds on the
wheels okay what did we do when it was
raining I I was taking the advice of the
developer to use it even if it's raining
so I did that on a couple of occasions
and it really didn't go so well so this
is what happens you could kind of see
it's just stuck in the mud just like
anything would get stuck in the mud if
you're moving around your foot could get
stuck in the mud you know and farmers
aren't going to operate there their
equipment their tillage equipment they
shouldn't be if it's really wet so
there's been consideration to make a mud
sensor of sorts so that it doesn't
operate when it's really muddy you could
see the leftover footprint of that that
kind of event so I didn't continue to do
that throughout the trial that happened
once and if it was raining I would just
delay the trial till it was dry enough
all right
total effect on weed cover measured by
my smartphone so the other data were
based on Scott and I looking at each
species and estimating ocularly the
percent cover this data is based on
putting out my my smartphone taking a
picture of the plot using canopy oh so
canopy o is just really simple app to
estimate the the ground cover and I
apologize these are not in the same
order on the x-axis but basically the
same result we D control is not that
much different than the turtle without
the trimmer but hen we did control is
pretty similar to what we were seeing
with the t plus and that was in august i
went back a month later i was really
curious just to see what happened a
month later after we stopped after we
stopped the trials no difference across
the treatments in the crop garden i was
astounded to see that there was still a
difference there was an effect of the
turtle with the trimmer treatment a
month later that was the only one that
was significantly different from from
the other treatments so there was a long
term effect which i really didn't
anticipate at all and it would be
interesting to look at that further
alright i'm not the only one looking at
turtle in kind of a an experimental way
arid gallon and some of his students up
at the university of maine have done a
little bit of work i have the website
here but they were looking at mustard
seated in in a greenhouse and they saw
pretty good results and they were
looking at dry and moist conditions so
that kind of uh
is a signal that the robot will work
differently depending on their soil
conditions the soil moisture and soil
type i think it's going to make a big
difference but even without the trimmer
they were seeing some promising results
so that led us to think more about the
wheel design these are two white wheels
that were 3d printed by joe he sent them
to us and that really got me thinking
how could how could we design some new
wheels well it turns out the 3d printers
on campus allow us to print new wheels
so i had my students design wheels this
past semester
in the fall and these were their their
hand ideas but they then designed the
wheels in man library in the makerspace
and printed them so I have the these
wheels up here that they printed a
student's design in the class as a class
project and so Chris citko and Josh
Fontaine I think they just left designed
these and he was my ta and a fall so he
designed this this bench arena and so we
we tested the wheels in the greenhouse
and you can see you even the production
wheels were getting a lot of soil stuck
to them but especially the wheels the
students designed I think because of the
material so the material of the wheel is
really important some materials are
going to shed soil a lot better than
another's
we cleaned off this one star wheel just
so you can see a little bit of what it
looked like the students got creative
they had sometimes different wheels in
the front versus the back and that's
this is the robot I have right here the
big wheels didn't fit in the in the
front of the robot so we have some
production wheels on there but I think
it was a really good project they got to
use a 3d printer and really think
through how can we disturb the soil just
at the surface akin to skin plowing to
have the same effect as what Joe had
been observing and and also at the
University of Maine just the wheels are
doing some of the weeding here so we had
a fun time doing that and I plan to do
it again
in my class so we did end up using the
the robots in in my course and in
addition we got some some neat data so
with that we just kind of go over the
highlights here the turtle with the
trimmer achieved weeding as good as hand
weeding so that's really a great result
I think that's more than what Joe would
be hoping for
and without the trimmer reduced we'd
cover in one field but not the other so
there's definitely an effect of soil and
plant community we're looking at turtle
being more effective and broadleaf
species or dicots versus monocots and
the
it just needs to be taken into account
still a very new area of Robotics and I
don't know Joe if you want to come up
here to redesigning the wheels offers
some potential for increasing the
efficacy and I'll let Joe talk to speak
a little bit to you yeah it's it's
robots are really hard it's really hard
to build one that that one does what
it's supposed to do and does it at a
cost that people can afford and that's
that last point is is the big dream that
we're that we were trying to get to it's
not going to happen this year or next
year but if we can make a success of the
company we're definitely going to keep
on working on on this track thank you
[Applause]
so yeah so so a couple of points there
on the on the issue of the HOS the what
we intend to do is to make the turtle
able to climb typical irrigation hoses
of like you know half an inch or
something some of our customers had
trouble with that initially and what we
advise them to do is to take a little
trench so the host will be down in it
the the robot is pretty good about its
pretty good at mobility basically we
spent a year the first year trying to
improve its mobility and and and make it
work well you can build a structure in
in your garden that the turtle can't get
over it can climb any a slope of about
20 degrees beyond that it turns away
because it doesn't want to trim tumble
over so we do recommend that it sort of
be rake smooth you rake the garden and
it's smooth enough the turtle work in
place like that oh they are in the
market yes you can buy one today the
$350 so the basically the way it works
there's a turtle discriminates between
crops and weeds based on height so if
the if it's taller than about if rather
if your if the plan is shorter than
about this it thinks that it's a weed
and they'll cut it down if it's about
three inches or so tall two or three
inches tall it thinks that its crop and
he'll turn away from it so it worked
really
with transplants if you have a
transplanted garden that kind of
protects your your crop plants yeah so
what the robot comes with are these
things that we call plant guides and
they look like tiny little tomato cages
so if you have a seedling you put the
the plant guide around it and then when
the and turtle will leave it alone when
it grows up as tall as the barrier on
the plant guide then you can take it
away if you want to and it'll it'll also
it's just based on height right if your
crop is less than one inch tall it'll
cut it down basically it is random and
there it's random is bad in that you
don't know exactly where it's gonna go
at any one time but it's good in the
same way that you know if you put a gas
into a bottle eventually the gas will
occupy all parts of the bottle right
even if it starts at one end and if you
let the turtle run long enough in a
garden eventually it will cover all
parts of the garden equally at least
that's the aim so you you can't really
make a since it doesn't know where it is
it can't create it can't follow a
pattern it only can follow a pattern
based on dead reckoning right it moves
forward and it figures out where it's
been by integrating its motions but that
there's so much as they say that the
error grows without bound so it doesn't
know where it is after he has wandered
around awhile we've actually had some
discussions with folks running landscape
companies who as a part of their service
weed home gardens and apparently there
they're there people don't like the
weeding of the garden so they're they're
considering just installing a robot in
their in their client site
yeah we are in discussions with massage
folks so these the wheels on a robot are
made out of ABS plastic which is a
simple you know it's cheap plastic they
also have a UV inhibitor in it otherwise
it has a stamp you have to live in the
outdoors throw to the Sun so it needs
the UV inhibitor not centigrade over
time but there are other options that we
really like to explore like Teflon or
Delran or maybe even metal or the weed
for the wheels would would be a better
material for not accumulating mud and
that just reminded me Joe has told me
that the product will probably last
three to five years
so that's pretty pretty neat it's not
going to be just a one-year thing well
the first thing we have to do is make
the robots work at an affordable price
if we can impact the e-waste issue by
making them live longer that that's a
good thing I know that there's a lot of
interest in in that sort of thing at our
company we haven't been able to to do a
lot of real steps yet but we'll work on
that
thank you all for coming and if you want
to check out the the robots feel free to
come up and check them out so thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu